what we got to talk about Ezekiel
Elliott for more on his contract
extension just announced this morning
and also some thoughts on natural gas
for joy now by Jerry Jones Comstock
resources majority investor and owner of
the NFL Dallas Cowboys Jerry
congratulations on both counts today
well it's great to be here on the floor
of the exchange probably fitting we're
playing New York this weekend but it's
great to have that 21 Zeke Elliott bag
but I am about a hundred million dollars
lighter but we are glad to have been
carrying the ball yes you are but it's
not all at once right there you know
first you mentioned the Giants game will
he be playing this week against the
Giants will he be practicing today very
much he's in great shape but one of the
great things about Zeke Elliott is he's
such an inspiration to the locker room
he's a role model in there he's in
excellent shape does everything right
physically but he's a football players
football player but he excites our
locker room before our games sometimes
he'll run up and down the locker room
like he's a Mustang just getting excited
and getting players excited it's gonna
be more than a hundred million dollars
but that's over six years that said
salary caps are rising does it continue
Jerry well I think so because I've never
been more bullish about the prospects of
the NFL
and frankly live sports we have such a
great place in the if you will in our
country and internationally with our
game our game the culminates its great
time is in the fourth quarter of the
year Thanksgiving Christmas that's when
you want to get those buyers and from
those TV sets
so our content is very valuable
continues to get more valuable a lot of
people say well it's a little soft it's
not the case it's the strongest thing on
television do you stay with 80 MTS
Direct TV or is the NFL speaking with
other potential partners Gerry well I
think this I think that all great
companies in the media business are
undergoing such a dramatic change how
they are going to present content and
the basis the flexibility is beyond
anything that any of us could ever have
imagined but I know AT&T personally I
know their leadership they'll get it
done they're one of the most admired by
me people on this and in the country and
the NFL wants to be a big part of a team
team's future and I think about the
valuation of your own team Gerry do you
think it's it's correctly value
particularly after today's contract
extension well I think this no one knows
what something is worth until the
marketplace until it's sold if you will
or bought that won't be the case for the
Dallas Cowboys I know that I would trade
a lot of those evaluations for more
first downs or more game wins at the end
of the day I didn't get into football to
make money I got into football to
compete and compete for Super Bowls on
the other hand it's with great pride
that we run the team and that we run it
in a way that has that kind of
recognition well did you get into
natural gas to make money because there
is 75% owner obviously of Comstock
resources and natural gas has been stuck
at around 3 $3 50 but that's well below
the $6 you need to actually be
profitable where do you see natural gas
prices well I think that of course
natural gas to be tried is a commodity
on the other hand it has all of the
things that you look for in commodities
it has to be in the right location the
cost of it either grow it or produce it
has to be really efficient to long term
make money comstock are joining with
Covey Park the place that we drilled the
leases that we have is the most
efficient place in the world to have
natural gas and our market is right
there and so we don't have very far to
go to get it and nowadays you get to
have ngl which is exported starting in
about 16 our country started exporting
the products of natural gas which is ng
this is what sparked my interest I got
the money to buy the Cowboys from
natural gas and the way I approached it
was from a marketing standpoint that's
the way that I do it
Comstock fits and checks all boxes I'm
excited consequently I put over a
billion and a half dollars of my
personal money in to this area
Haynesville area Comstock area of
natural gas right so Hanes the last year
coffee park you're announcing today and
this year what's next in terms of
acquisitions for consec well I think
this we certainly want to get even more
efficient we want to mail these
companies together take the best of both
in terms of the talent and the personnel
is still about people just like football
it's about people but make no mistake
about it just because it's not going
good as an industry when I bought the
Cowboys they were losing a million in a
month the industry was ostensibly going
down yes the industry does not in any
way dictate the promise of the
individual or company in the industry
that's the way it is with Comstock I
think we've got a chance to be a leader
as people get more confidence and what
and how much money you can make
and natural gas business well Jerry I
think you're gonna have to extend your
stay in New York because I do believe
the Giants game on Sunday will be one
exciting one congratulations to you and
your team Dallas Cowboys also of course
your Comstock Resources deal today
thanks for joining from the NYSC
this is Mary thank you thank you new job
fans be sweet